Yoshio Benji pointed out that
consciousness is no longer a dirty word
in cognitive neuroscience it's clearly
an evolutionary advantage for us to have
consciousness and Benji oh says that we
should have a formal definition of
consciousness so that we can incorporate
it as a prior in our machine learning
algorithms first have you ever
questioned the nature of your reality
Benji okie noted at this year's I CLR
conference along with young Laocoon and
today we are going to analyze his
presentation
benjoe takes on quite the challenge in
this talk he tries to connect elements
from psychology and neuroscience such as
system one system to thinking and the
different areas of the brain to things
that we know from deep learning and
thereby he formulates a theory of
thinking and consciousness and what sort
of role deep learning plays in the
future of our push for artificial
intelligence
I appreciate that he makes definitive
statements here and statements that
leave him vulnerable to criticism by
making very precise claims about
consciousness intelligence and things
like working memory attention in this
talk yoshua bengio
presents a unifying view of topics to
achieve better generalization in deep
learning and even get the magic out of
consciousness
Benji owes talk from NURBS 2019 from
system 1 deep learning to system 2 deep
learning brought ideas from Daniel
Kahneman's Thinking Fast and Slow into
the minds of machine learning scientists
yoshiya Benji I was born in 1964 in
Paris he's one of the three Godfather's
of deep learning he's a professor at the
department of computer science and
operations research at the University of
Montreal and scientific director of the
Montreal Institute of learning
algorithms Ben geo received his PhD from
McGill University and was a postdoctoral
fellow at MIT he's one of the most cited
computer scientists on the planet in
October 2016 benzio co-founded element
AI a montreal-based artificial
intelligence incubator
turns a I research into real-world
business applications benzio was named
an Officer of the Order of Canada the
same year he was nominated fellow of the
Royal Society of Canada and together
with Geoffrey Hinton and Yan laocoon
benzio won the 2018 cheering award my
collaborators and I are trying to
understand the limitations of
guarantee.i which is using machine
learning a lot of deep learning we are
very interested in the perspective of
how agents like animals and humans who
act in their environment actually have
some understanding of their environment
understand that the causal relationships
in it and how they can reason in it by
doing things that current learning based
systems are not really yet good at but
that humans are very good at the reason
I got into AI when I was in my early 20s
is because I thought that intelligence
was one of the biggest mystery that
science needed to understand been
Geoscience Daniel Kahneman's dichotomous
system 1 and system 2 modality of
thinking system 1 is the fast intuitive
habitual and non-linguistic mode we
drive our cars and we recognize dogs
using system 1 system 2 is our slow
logical linguistic conscious thinking
mode allowing us to plan and reason with
explicit knowledge the Chomsky famously
argued that language was externalized
thought one general assumption about
language almost a Dogma and philosophy a
common understanding linguistic ecology
is that language is primarily a means of
communication and that it evolved as a
means of communication probably that's
totally false
it seems that languages evolved and is
designed as a mode of creating and
interpreting thought it's a system of
thought basically it can be used to
communicate everything people do can be
used
okay you can you communicate by your
hairstyle you know style of walk
everything and yes language can be used
to communicate but it doesn't seem to be
part of its design its design seems to
be radically different and in fact even
seems to undermine communication if you
look at carefully at the structure of
language you find case after case right
at the core of language design where
there are conflicts between what would
be efficient for communication and what
is efficient for the specific biological
design of language one of the things I
really liked about been Gio's
presentation is that he asserted that a
lot of implicit system 1 knowledge
cannot be verbalized or explained
there's a lot of noise in the machine
learning community at the moment about
explain ability I like the idea that a
lot of knowledge cannot be verbalized
and therefore cannot be explained I
think the emphasis should be on model
robustness and generalization and error
testing there are many things which we
are competent at yet we cannot verbalize
or explain any attempt to do so in my
opinion is mere confabulation anyone
who's taken psychedelics before can
attest to the ineffable conscious
experience language itself appears to be
part of our system to apparatus Jannik
disagreed with me on this he thought
that it was possible to verbalize system
one activities what fascinates me is
that our language only covers the domain
of our shared physical reality this
seems to contradict Chomsky's claim that
thinking comes before externalized
language now you said human do you think
if those intelligent creatures are out
there do you think they experience their
world they are evolved if they are
product of natural evolution as it would
have to be they will also experience
their own world so consciousness isn't
just human your ID it's it's much wider
it's probably it may be spread across
all of biology we have the only thing
that we have special is we can talk
about it of course not all people can
talk about it one of the things I took
issue with in Benji's presentation was
his assertion that consciousness is only
a system to phenomena
this appears to fly in the face of the
wisdom of some of the experts in the
field that claim that consciousness is
merely experience and that it is
experienced throughout the animal
kingdom experience consciousness is any
experience some people call it
subjective feeling some people call it
phenomenology some people call it qualia
of the Philosopher's they all denote the
same thing it feels like something in
the famous word of as if a loss at
Thomas Nagel it feels like something to
be a bad or to be an American or to be
angry or to be sad or to be in love or
to have pain that is what experience is
any possible experience could be as
mundane as just sitting in a chair could
be as exalted as having a mystical
moment in in deep meditation those are
just different forms of experiences in
my opinion we should stay the
conversation away from consciousness and
focus on intelligence itself much like
many people in the field including
Francois Chalet are doing at the moment
it's gonna require consciousness which
is not things that would normally be
required by an intelligent system you do
get you know we were mentioning earlier
like science as superhuman
problem-solving agent north system it
does not have consciousness enough
emotions in general so emotions
I see consciousness is being understand
spectrum as emotions it is a component
of the subjective experience that is
meant very much to guide behavior
generation right hands meant to guide
your behavior enjoy human intelligence
and animal intelligence as evolved for
the purpose of behavior generation right
including in a social context so that's
why we actually need emotions that's why
we need consciousness an artificial
intelligence system developed in
different context may well never need
them the way may will never be conscious
like science I think intelligence is
essentially the efficiency with which
you turn experience into generalizable
programs so what that means is it's the
efficiency with which you turn a
sampling of experience base into the
ability to process a larger chunk of
experience base this is what Christof
Koch said on the Lex Friedman podcast
unclear whether the intelligence we're
engineering has anything to do with
consciousness and whether it can
experience anything because
fundamentally what's the difference
intelligence is about function
intelligence no matter exactly how you
define it sort of an adaptation to new
environments being able to learn and
quickly understand you know the set up
of this and what's going on and who the
active some what's gonna happen next
gets all about function consciousness is
not about function consciousness is
about being it's in some sense much
fundamental consciousness is something
that interests me though I've been
meditating every day with Sam Harris's
waking up at one of the things he tries
to do in his practice is to get you to
conceptualize that the self is an
illusion he will ask you whether there
is a locus of consciousness and whether
you are behind your face he will ask you
to look at things in your visual field
and to reason about whether there is a
subject object relationship between you
and what you're looking at ultimately he
describes consciousness as being like an
ocean it has a surface and thoughts that
come into your head are a bit like waves
on the surface of that ocean he wants
you to conceptualize yourself as being
an executive or program self dot exe
which runs in the operating system of
your consciousness why am I telling you
this it goes to show that quite often we
try to use language we try to use
analogies to describe what's going on in
our conscious experience but we're
always reaching we can never quite
describe what's in our conscious
experience because it's ineffable its
ineffable because there is no language
in our shared physical reality that we
can develop to describe what we are
experiencing so sam harris goes on to
explain in this following clip that
consciousness is quite clearly system
one it just is what we are experiencing
in this moment here what we truly have
is this moment and this and and we spend
most of our lives forgetting this truth
repudiating it fleeing it overlooking it
and and the the horror is that we
succeed we managed to never really
connect with the present moment and find
fulfillment there because we are
continually hoping to become happy in
the future and the future never arrives
this presentation continues on this idea
and I'm really looking forward to
discussing the general idea of system 1
and system 2 thinking as well as how it
relates to deep learning Benjy oh ties
in several areas of research at play to
achieve systematic generalization a
particular kind of Adam domain
generalization whereby the test
distribution is different from the
training one but follows the same rules
of semantic and syntactic composition
Benjy owners collaborators explored
systematic generalization on the clever
data set in a paper titled closure
closure tests how visual question
answering systems learn to reason about
the arrangement of objects in 3d space
an example of systematic generalization
here is to go from answering questions
such as the object that is the same size
as the red cube to out of distribution
questions like the cylinder to the left
of the object that is the same size as
the red cube in their closure paper they
find the most success with a vector
representation variant of neural module
networks an interesting approach to
routing different kinds of computation
for different questions I'm really
looking forward to discussing these
kinds of networks as well as the topics
of sparse factor graphs and causality
attention in consciousness and how many
learning across tasks and data sets fits
into this picture I enjoyed this talk
and I hope you enjoy us coming to terms
with what benjin says even though I
disagree on some of his claims I had a
lot of fun doing this and I hope you
have fun too
Cheers remember to Like comment and
subscribe
bribe and we will see you back next week
hey folks and welcome back to the
machine learning Street talk issue
channel with me and scarf and my two
compadres Yannick Kilcher and college
shorter it's been an incredibly exciting
week for us actually because last week
we did a reaction to Yamla Coons keynote
presentation at AI CLR and he retweeted
us and the you also made a post on
Facebook and we've just been absolutely
elated by that it's great are you our
view graph was like this and as soon as
he posted it shot up straight fantastic
so yeah thank you very much for that we
really really appreciate it and he even
made a post on his Twitter afterwards
saying that it was really interesting
for him just to see how a guys like us
could wrestle with the material in his
presentation and because some things and
some things we struggled with and for
someone at Yan's level he can't even
imagine what it would be like to you
know not not the other wizard deep
learning so it was really interesting
for him as well yeah I knew everyone
that watched of course I mean this this
means a lot to us and ultimately we're
just rambling here and figure out that
people are actually interested in this
is a big compliment to us today we're
going to continue with the ICL our 2020
theme immediately after yam the Coons
presentation Yoshio benzio one of the
other godfathers of deep learning went
on to do a really interesting
presentation and today we just want to
step through that as well because we
think it's really interesting I think he
did the same presentation that new
Europe's as well at the end of last year
so it's definitely something that NGO
has been putting a lot of thought into
at the moment yeah I think there's so
many interesting ideas with it and I'm
really interested in the idea of meta
learning and particularly meta learning
in the context of saying here are a
bunch of tasks the mutual information of
all these tasks like Google's recent
meta data set or things like the visual
tasks adaptation benchmark
like this idea that looking at different
tasks can help us find these high-level
features that help us generalize inform
these transfers this kind of transfer to
out of distribution error and so another
thing that I really thought was
interesting is he's pretty particular
with his language he doesn't just say
generalization he says systematic
generalization so I think it's
interesting particularly in my closure
where they study the clever data set and
what those models learn is looking at
the particular kind of ways we want
these models to generalize not just a
random generalization test but
particularly trying to see if they can
derive rules like one example from
closure is in this clever data set
there's a bunch of these like objects in
three dimensions and you have to say
things like the object that is the same
size as the red cube and the model would
answer something like the orange
triangle or whatever so the idea of
systematic generalization would be can
it then do the cylinder to the left of
the object that is the same size as the
cube as the red cube to seeing if this
particular kind of generalization so I
think that kind of being specific about
that language is really interesting as
well I want to touch on Francois chalets
definition of intelligence as well said
in his paper on the measure of
intelligence he talks about developer
aware generalization and systemic
generalization and also four degrees of
generalization so it'd be really good to
touch from that it's really interesting
to me to hear and this talk of system 1
versus system 2 and I had always thought
of system 2 as being referenced in in
the context of expert systems from the
1980s and those things were very brittle
and they were the antithesis of
generalization but this is a little bit
different NGOs talking about how these
high-level concept can be recombined in
many different ways and will allow you
to generalize to things that you've
never seen before in training so this is
definitely something I'd like to explore
as well yeah it's so interesting to me
to take like let's be more specific
about generalization and try to like
exactly pick apart the different areas
of generalization or trying to test it's
not just about training it on a cat vs.
dog classifier than seeing what it does
with
but like more specific without
generalizes I think well we'll have to
get into it I mean this the talk the
talk flows really nicely and I think Ben
Joe explains what he means
fairly well throughout the talk and
there's a lot of interesting stuff
pickup
oh my name is Josh revenger and I'm
going to tell you about future
directions for deep learning in
particular about deep learning priors
associated with conscious processing so
consciousness has been studied in
neuroscience and punk and neuroscience
with a lot of progress in the last
couple of decades and I think it's time
for machine learning to consider these
advances and incorporate them in machine
learning models this could also be
helpful for consciousness research by
helping to formalize and test specific
hypothesized functionalities of
consciousness help to get some of the
magic out of consciousness understand
the evolutionary advantage of
consciousness the computational and
statistical advantage for example I'll
told you tell you about systematic
Malaysian and of course provide these
same advantages that we believe humans
have to learning agents as well so I
think one of the big things here is that
he wants to remove the magic out of
consciousness and he wants to formalize
it and he wants to incorporate this
formalized notion of consciousness into
machine learning as an absolutely giant
task
let's let's let's just take
consciousness and put it into machine
learning is I mean there's so many
unsolved things here like what is
consciousness as he says why is it here
and the evolutionary advantage so
basically what we problem that
consciousness was basically it's to
solve and maybe get a hint of that we
might be able to deduce how
consciousness works or what it's for
he's gonna he's going on to have a very
specific model of consciousness but I
think the the entry point is very good
to say basically okay there's this thing
called consciousness and we humans have
it and since we want to develop
something like human level AGI it might
be useful for a machine learning system
or for an AI to
also have this consciousness property
and he talks about the evolutionary
advantage of consciousness in respect of
systemic generalizations so he's saying
that it has been a huge advantage and
that's why we have this cognitive
ability to generalize yeah I mean
something we're gonna get into later is
definitely like my thinking of it now is
that like consciousness is enabled by
attention over these like perception
representations that deep learning has
has discovered already so
yeah I mean it's almost kind of like
scary to think about but I guess I'm
willing to believe in the idea of like
simulation theory a little bit but the
idea that it could be that everything is
simulated and I guess from this I don't
think that you know I think that
machines could be conscious after
watching this well there's a couple of
things there because there's Nick
Bostrom is this philosopher and he had
the argument from simulation and it goes
roughly along the lines of how many
possible civilizations are there in the
universe that developed a technical
sophistication high enough to create a
simulation of the universe and he makes
a reasonable argument that there are
more than one if there are more
simulations than there are real
universes then it stands to reason that
there's a pretty good chance that we are
in a simulation ourselves my problems
with that because the this is kind of
predicated on the notion that then
within the simulation maybe the
simulated ones would again simulate and
so on you get this explosion ultimately
the probability that you're in a
simulated universe is close to one
that's not really thought through
probably there is like a physical limit
to how much this recursion can go just
by the nature of physics of the universe
and it's better to think you're in the
real world so I just don't accept the
argument that's super interesting and I
think that the thrust of the argument
though is to serve as a mental thought
experiment that you could reduce
consciousness down to information
processing is that something that sits
well with you or not well is is the
question whether your consciousness
itself is simulated or is it just like
matrix style that you're somewhere in a
in a box and you're plugged into the
simulation well that's really
interesting as well so one view is that
if you were a materialist you believe
that your entire conscious self is
physically contained inside your brain
and you're likely to think that is
achieved with information processing and
other conceptualization is that we are
plugged into the matrix or the actual
processing Nexus is in the cloud somehow
we like thin clients and the processing
happens some
where else yeah but then at some point
it makes no difference anymore whether
you're in a simulation or not right if
everything's just processing and the
other part is consciousness actually
come in like if if level 2 thinking is
simply attention over these
representations that that doesn't mean
consciousness yet all right like is it
saying so basically if I build a system
that does attention over these
high-level concept is it conscious I
don't think so consciousness is somewhat
the awareness of the thoughts about the
thoughts itself it's like this meta
awareness of these thoughts right
thoughts about thoughts and the the
questions still in and throughout angels
talk basically for me was always weird
is exactly consciousness come in because
he just defines consciousness as what he
defines it as but I don't I don't see it
the same way there was a wonderful quote
in the France Wachtel a paper by Rene
Descartes in 1637 and it was incredibly
prescient for him to say this back then
he said even though such machines might
do some things as well as we do them or
perhaps even better they would
inevitably fail in others which would
reveal that they were acting not through
understanding but only from the
disposition of their organs so he said
that in in the 16th century and he made
the extremely astute observation that
simply performing a task is not the same
as understanding it or even having the
capability to learn it imagine like such
a complex task and we already have the
neural architecture with thoughts about
thoughts we have meta learning learning
algorithms where we have the low-level
perception the attention on the
low-level perception and then we might
even just put an attention over that so
it's not like we don't have an idea of
the architecture that could think about
thoughts and so imagine this crazy
complex environment and then even an
environment where like our own reward
isn't clearly defined like we're
constantly evaluating our own state of
mind to see what reward are we really
pursuing even that's like I imagine any
kind of information processing
and that has that fine grain that's
trying to say what is my reward what is
my environment I have all this high
dimensional stuff and I'm constantly
going through these levels of processing
I think it's totally possible
that's what consciousness arises bro
absolutely I would agree with that and
let's contrast that to what we have now
because Connor sent this wonderful
article up not actually read this but it
was by this chap called Christoph Concha
and he was kind of asserting about
intelligence and he was talking about
this causal power onto itself so he said
that the firing of neurons in the brain
that caused other neurons to fire a bit
later is one example and this made me
think because if you look at a neural
network now it's basically a computer
program it's not intelligent at all it's
not like a normal computer program
written with code it's it's just a bunch
of neurons or the network but for all
intents and purposes it's a computer
program but the reflec sylheti seems to
be the important bit so if the program
could trigger itself if it could create
this reflexive loop of computation could
that then develop into consciousness
that's the argument I was making
actually is it's a difference between
stacking attentions on top of one
another and having the attention
mechanism attending to itself I'd
understand this let me talk about two
kinds of systems that Daniel Cameron
Kahneman described very clearly in his
book Thinking Fast and Slow the system
one tasks in system two tasks
so it's just one tasks imagine you're
driving in a known path you don't
actually have to give all your attention
to the driving somebody can talk to you
and you can respond since the two tasks
require your attention your conscious
attention and if you're driving in a new
place that requires you to think to plan
and someone to talk to you at the same
time since one house involves intuitive
knowledge it can be executed quickly in
a unconsciously they may happen in one
step in parallel in your brain actually
they are hard to explain verbally and
they can be executed in the habit you'll
way
the regards implicit knowledge and this
is what current deep learning is good
what we want to extend is we want to do
is to extend deep learning to also
handle system two tasks which are
executed slowly consciously in a
conscious way could be described
verbally for everything algorithmic
involving reasoning or planning and
explicit knowledge one interesting
property of system two tasks and
conscious processing in general is that
the allowed to manipulate high-level
semantic concepts which can then be
recombined combinatorially in in level
situations so there's a protection to
out of distribution generalization like
in my driving example is lots to pick
apart there the first thing I want to
pick apart is the jargon now quite often
people in machine learning talk about
semantics things and what that means in
my opinion is if you were Google or a
few of the Bing team you would want to
build up a semantics with you of the web
and semantic it just means information
that I'm interested in so if you were
building a dog classifier the dog would
be semantic if you were google and you
were parsing web pages and products and
people would be semantic information I
think there's another level to like one
of it is paper I don't know this is
Benjy actually but he talks about neural
module networks a lot that are looking
at different ways to combine different
types of operations so like one common
way is let's say you're doing to
classify whether I have a peace sign up
or you know whatever gesture I'm doing
you might break that up into an object
detection model and then you might
deploy the pose detection on my hand so
it's me one interpretation of system two
in system one a system two is trying to
combine these different tasks in the
ways that make the problem more
tractable to system one tasks that
combine other system one tasks right
because it basically says any anything
that's sort of and this is a very human
view I think we've talked about this
last week said anything that for
human seems very you know intuitive fast
implicit muscle memory whatever the
contrary to what he says here please
don't talk while driving even if it's a
road you know I love the second stock
photo by the way don't also beat system
one is anything that's intuitive and you
can intuitively combine also neural
modules I think system two is more where
where you have to consciously think
about it the sequential is in red and
the conscious is in bold that's both
means important I think and and and the
conscious is in caps as well so makes it
clear that you want the system to is
anything where you sort of have to spend
mental effort to come to a conclusion
whereas the the system one almost
happens like radically like you don't
have to actually mental effort to
achieve it one thing that really
interests me is he talks about system
two as being better for generalization
system two can mean symbolic approaches
and I liken that to in the 1980s when
there were knowledge graphs and the
reason we stopped using those where they
were very brittle and they did not
generalize and how else can a machine
hope to understand what's going on
except through learning if you're not
learning what else you doing while
you're putting all the knowledge into
the system and that just feels like
something which decades of AI have told
us is maybe not a dead end but certainly
has a ceiling to the capabilities it's
known as the knowledge acquisition
bottleneck that the more you try to put
into something the more brittle the
system becomes and and so you just have
to have learning you have to have
learning that's the only way you're
going to be able to get a system which
has sufficient knowledge in it you know
millions and millions of pieces of
knowledge billions trillions of a form
that it can actually apply for itself
and understand how those billions and
trillions of pieces of knowledge can be
leveraged in a way which will actually
lead it towards its goal without
conflict or other issues but now we're
talking about system two
an explicit verbalise herbal knowledge
again in the setting that it can
generalize and NGO goes on to talk about
you can have re combinations of these
assistant to semantic objects the really
interesting thing about system two is
that the things that the semantic
objects that you reason about can be
verbalized they tend to be words in the
English language and Noam Chomsky was
famous for saying that language is a
system of thought when we speak to each
other using language it's kind of like
externalized thought which is really
interesting because system one is also
sequential if you look at a neural
network it's as we were saying last week
it's a sequence of manifold
transformations but the key thing is
that it can't be verbalized or
understood using our language concepts
and this is one of the reasons why I am
quite skeptical about explain ability
because he's kind of implying that
system 2 is explained the book as we can
verbalize it and system one isn't
explainable I can't explain to you why I
recognized a dog
I didn't say maybe it ties into
embodiment a bit as well the reason
language is so explainable is because
that's the purpose of it even though
when I get to make a coffee and I'm
thinking in my own head not
communicating to anyone I'm still
thinking in language I'm not thinking in
some abstract space what's like a good
example of a system two systems system
two things so we can have this clear
this is system one this is system two so
to me the thing is hierarchical
reinforce learning or you're designing a
plan is the system to level and then
system one is the execution of the plan
do you think that's the best example of
this to paint this picture that is a
very very good example though we have to
be a bit careful with something like a
search because I'm especially passed
planning I'm always so amazed by like my
human ability to pass fun you know when
you're like running on a bit of a dirt
path and all of a sudden a bunch of
puddle isn't an hour in front of you
right and the the the speed with which
you plan your way through these puddles
where your steps are gonna go is
absolutely staggering to me like every
time I consciously experience this and I
watch myself plan
path through something like this this is
crazy and this this is still a system
one like my my ability to to
approximately path find something is
still so not not all over like search is
system to tasks even though we can't do
it with deep learning it but the analogy
is very good like if I want to achieve a
goal and that I don't know how to do I
have to spend mental efforts to make a
plan until I break it down to the pieces
that I know right and then that is just
all the autopilot
you know search search like becomes
system one through experience right like
even in our like to go first to our auto
ml things we have these like where you
can predict the performance of a program
based on it's like genotype so like a
large-scale evolution of image
classifiers we have this like genotype
that defines rendering classifier if you
search through like eighty thousand of
those you'll start to be able to predict
performance from the genotype itself
it's like when I see someone on like a
skateboard riding through campus I'm
like this guy's gonna crash into
somebody cuz I imagine myself riding a
skateboard the games I'm freakin
crashing everybody as soon as the
experience accumulates the search
problem of navigating becomes so much
easier lighted people have said to me
recently that reinforcement learning is
system to I was speaking to to a guy who
runs a reinforcement learning company in
Europe actually let me share my screen
to show you the the anecdote that he
gave me basically I called to
the guy I said look you know you're
talking about reinforcement learning I
think it's still system one because I've
just watched Ben Gio's talk and even
before we show this it might be
instructive to you to show this
wonderful YouTube video that's Connard
descent earlier about chips so this is
system one and this video basically
shows a bunch of chips apparently have
better working memory than us you can
mask the numbers and they remember where
the numbers are and that they can press
them in sequence in order to get a
peanut and on one instance the monkey
got distracted for about 30 seconds and
then turned the monkeys attention back
to the screen that still managed to
remember it's incredible what monkeys
can achieve and this chap Harry
he came back to me and he talked about
this experimental setup so he said one
set up there's a hidden classification
rule and a deck of cards which have some
kind of figures on them the test subject
picks cards one by one then is forced to
classify them into one of two classes
there's feedback about correct and
incorrect choices after each card in
some cases the test subjects never
become aware of the hidden rule but
gradually learn to make better and
better choices sometimes typically when
the hidden rule is relatively simple and
depends on just one input feature like
the color or the shape of a figure the
test subject becomes aware of the rule
and the classification performance of
properly jumps to a hundred percent this
kind of Eureka moment is rarely seen in
monkeys doing the same task they have
virtually the same performance as humans
as long as the task remains a big data
system one learning task but humans
perform at an entirely different level
if they manage to engage system to
cognition so if you see this rapid jump
what it means is that human beings can
somehow turn it into one of these
consciousness priors and reason about it
in some level of abstraction that's
above system one analogy with with the
rules it might be a good one but I don't
think it's in general that that monkeys
cannot do that I think there's enough
examples in the animal kingdom where
exactly this type of thing is happening
where there's like a snap moment like ah
that's how you do it and then not only
that but then other monkeys watch these
monkeys and can like instantly transfer
learn I mean the only difference here is
they they probably can't communicate
their solution through language well
this is something that Chalet talks
about in his AARC
benchmark and data set because the
problem with so many intelligence tests
is that it's possible to learn shortcuts
yeah absolutely I mean that the notion
that RL is a system to task I have not
seen an RL system that gets the Eureka
that like discovers the rule RL is the
exact opposite like oh we'll just brute
force around until the reward gets good
and then it will just repeat whatever
well that's super interesting though a
Eureka moment would be
noticeable on the training convergence
behavior and and something benzio talks
about later in this talk is this notion
of you can determine causality between
variables based on the speed of learning
and exactly that in a reinforcement
learning algorithm that the convergence
is exactly the same well so does that
not indicate that there's no system to
not necessarily because it's not only
the convergent that you see that in RL
systems like as soon as they like figure
out a path that leads to good reward
they can like the performance can jump
very quickly but that doesn't mean
they've learned the rule you had you'd
have to explicitly measure on a new task
that is different but the rule remains
constant and that's where really we get
into what been just gonna say later he's
basically gonna talk about what if the
what if you have this high level concept
and you have to learn how they connect
to each other and that enables you to
generalize to a different set of high
level objects but that connect in the
same way right and and that's and that's
really what we don't see from any
machine learning so far and the the idea
of building these knowledge graphs was
actually very smart because clearly this
is going on in humans
clearly we reason about like about these
entities but the brittleness that you
know you have to pinpoint the exact
entity you're talking about in the AI
system was just devastating so now that
we can maybe solve this riddle less we
can come back to that
on the side of the Eureka moment idea is
we discuss in chalets intelligence paper
this analogy of
UNCHR um playing a piece of paper don't
you think the Eureka moment is just like
you're transforming the data manifold as
you go from ridiculously high complex
the true visual data manifold into these
compressed data manifolds don't you
think it's like UNCHR umple UNCHR um
pelant is like oh I got it now I now the
points are separated Eureka moment would
be if you could um crumble a new piece
of paper in in one step right I could
have you discovered how to how to do
this I'll give you a different one and
you can just be like snap that's how
you'd like the difference between
learning to kind of solve a Rubik's Cube
by getting better and like more and more
to what you want to meet telling you
here's the here's the barrels yeah I
think an interesting idea you're getting
so I've learned to UNCHR umple this one
cat image I've uncompelled it it's a
layer like II is now when my cat image
can be classified as a cat so is this is
the idea that now the next time I get a
cat image I don't have to go through
eight rounds of UNCHR um playing i can
just run crumpled on the first layer is
that the idea it's more like the next
idea you get a date to set where two
things are different well maybe that's
that's that's too much different but
it's like the generalization across
these categories I put something that
Harry said was that system two is slow
to think but fast to learn I think that
that's something that we should linger
on for a second in the example Connor
just gave at first it takes a long time
to recognize this cat but if there were
a system to of consciousness it's almost
like there would be a kind of short cut
off after that the initial recognition
yes maybe what happens is you need a lot
of capacity to learn how to uncouple it
at layer a and then you do the knowledge
distillation some fast Network GlobalNet
so you can have some faster forward pass
network and so it uses the big network
and then it lets it into that and now
you're like yeah
two seconds compared to 20 seconds or
whatever
that's really interesting maybe that
happened maybe our intelligence produces
skill programs and what when a program
works the brain then works on a higher
level of abstraction executing those
skill programs
that's like saying that the the act of
learning itself is a system to program
questions are there other system to
programs except from learning
I mean don't know but I think bench is
gonna make that that I'm here that there
are other system to tasks than learning
for example planning yeah
college that we have in our brain about
the world he'd be more or less separated
into two kinds the implicit knowledge
and the verbalize about knowledge and my
main message is that revisable knowledge
is a special kind of knowledge that
satisfies some assumptions that we
should try to ever and describe so we
can put them in machine learning
architectures and training Printworks so
the this knowledge is organized around
concepts that we can name with language
and so there's a strong connection
between that research and building
better natural language understanding
for example and the priors could extend
deep learning incorporate the kind of
sure that exists for these high-level
concepts deduced ok just came to mind
because he says basically system 2 is
what you can verbalize but times i'm
verbalizing system 1 things like if i
have to explain to someone how to shoot
a basketball right if this is very
intuitive to me but then i can sort of
introspect and talk about what i'm doing
in order to transmit this to the other
person so this would be put more weight
on this hypothesis that maybe all system
2 is is is learning and distilling
things into system 1 things and then I
can transfer my system 1 knowledge to
someone by via system - are there any
system 1 activities which are not
physical that are entirely in your brain
that you could verbalize
because I think his point was the reason
they're not verbalize a ball is when you
describe how you shoot a basketball
it's a real-world concept so there's a
whole language and vernacular you have
to describe the physical movements when
you recognize a dog you wouldn't be able
to explain to me how you do that well
yeah I mean attempt I can say look it
has these gears and so on and I can be
very specific about the things I can
even describe sort of pixel patterns I
can describe it fully but I can still
make the language claims about my system
one knowledge but I think he would be
making it up if he did and the humans
have this tendency because we have this
cognitive dissonance that we like to
delude ourselves that we understand the
way our brains work and quite often when
you ask humans to recount why they did
something they'll confabulate and
they'll basically make it up can teach
someone how to throw a basketball right
like how do you how do you explain that
indeed you can and because the
physicality of it is verbalized able
okay you can you can turn that into a
program and can emit it with language it
can be received by another person they
can execute the program and then their
system one brain will burn it indirectly
yeah maybe
I mean maybe here the idea is like we
only have kind of system 1 and system 2
comes from like our communication with
each other and it's like it's like maybe
without if you were like a human just
one in the world you maybe wouldn't you
know you maybe wouldn't have systems to
it all because never would need to
verbalize it but then you maybe also
wouldn't be this smart because
verbalizing we verbalize our knowledge
even in our own mind we'd like to make
notes and write things down to virt to
distill it within ourselves
so maybe consciousness is a shared thing
we all are system one things and now we
all share this system to consciousness
is the whole language itself is our
shared consciousness well that's
interesting as well because language is
externalized and Vishal a talks about
this as well then there are many types
of intelligence in the real world some
some of it we don't recognize as being
intelligence like evolution natural
evolution is a wonderful form of
intelligence and it's open-ended and
it's very adaptable and so on so there
is a form of intelligence which is
externalized that then bends the
definition of intelligence a bit I mean
if you say in evolution is intelligence
well why not well it just depends on
what you mean by intelligence and your
case if there are many different kinds
of intelligence but I say that as well
and just redefine intelligence until the
thing I want to be intelligent fits in
that like the book is intelligent
because it contains many smart things
well I love chalets conception so he
says that intelligence is the efficiency
and which a learning system turns
experience and priors into skill a
previously unknown task that evolution
is terrible as that at that what's great
about evolution though is its
adaptability because shalay has this
this thing you know he says that in the
1970s we thought that when we solved
chess when we could make a chess program
that that would be intelligent because
to play chess you need to have reasoning
and planning and so on and basically it
was a brute-force search algorithm now
we've done the same thing of
reinforcement learning but we've done a
brute force learning algorithm so we
just have millions of millions of
iterations and and chalet is saying
skill is easy you can by skill with
unlimited priors and experience you can
just throw loads of training data at it
and that's why any measure of
intelligence needs to be looking at
things like the efficiency of acquiring
new tasks garry kasparov is intelligent
not because he has a skill but because
he had the capability that capacity to
learn and acquire that skill and that
skill is something that generalizes you
could be looking most of these
reinforcement learning approaches from
deep mind or from open AI that the five
the dota thing they have almost no
flexibility they're completely locked to
a specific customization of the game I
think on the go algorithms from deep
mind if you even increase the board size
then the algorithm would need to be
retrained from scratch it has no
generalization power whatsoever but so
what the humans evolution has taken
about a billion years to come up with
something that can barely play chess and
this this the who algorithm it can
generalize to to a
a new chess game in like with no
expenditure at all okay if you change
the rules but then you have to retrain
the humans as well well this is
interesting as well because I want to
get into this because I would cool the
deep-blue chess algorithm and expert
system it's algorithmic and by
definition it has no generalization
power but actually it does it has
generalization power in the same way a
sorting algorithm does a sorting
algorithm can generalize to any
permutation of numbers that it's not
learning an abstract representation but
it can verbalize anything it's doing
right deep-blue will tell you exactly
I'm doing this smooth because because
it's Depot is basically a search tree
search over a mixture of handcrafted
features so it can tell you always like
oh this this handcrafted feed material
is very good in this path right and it
can verbalize pretty much perfectly what
it's doing
but it's a program yes
and so this is a diagram from Sciales
paper and I thought this was really
interesting so in the searching that
there's a difference between
intelligence itself and a skill program
so in his concession of intelligence
these skill programs can be generated
dynamically and he would argue that on
the latest deepmind alphago alpha0
system that was just a skill program so
it's a static program and it has no
intelligence whatsoever it was created
from an intelligence system and he would
argue that that intelligence system was
the creators of the reinforcement
learning algorithm well for the sake of
our focus on consciousness could the
skill program have consciousness as well
or another way of asking it is is the
intelligence system also a skill program
doesn't have to be right if the skill
program is a human and the intelligence
system is evolution devolution conscious
I think that's rather it's rather
disconnected from the consciousness is
disconnected from this is the
consciousness or the intelligence system
maybe could be like a collective
consciousness through language and then
I can we interface with the collective
consciousness for our own system one
maybe we only really would have that
it's true I mean I mean other other
species can communicate right through
language but they have sort of a proto
language and of course let us assume I
don't know if they are conscious or not
because of that but you can certainly
think of communication without
consciousness that's certainly something
that's possible because communication
based consistent transmission of
information and you can do that without
being conscious right and you can be
apparently intelligent without being
conscious so if intelligence is just
this ability to generalize to new tasks
to reduce these skill programs you don't
have to be conscious for that but
consciousness requires this kind of
introspection introspection ability
about the consciousness itself and it's
also not clear that a conscious system
necessarily has to be intelligent why do
we need consciousness why don't we just
throw it away because it seems to me
that NGO is is implying that we need
system too and we need consciousness in
order to improve intelligence and I
think that's bollocks I mean look at
look at so many other examples of
intelligence like evolution that are
clearly not conscious well it well yes
maybe
well the question is why do is evolution
is evolution intelligent at the same
quality and quantity of intelligence as
we want AI to achieve and the answer is
probably no we want the I to achieve a
sort of intelligence like humans and the
only way that has ever happened is with
consciousness so I think the motivation
here is purely phenomenological is that
you say the only thing we know that
works has this consciousness thing so we
might as well try to build this into the
AI I wrote the natural selection
evolution perspective obviously the
better that you
tend over your own problem-solving thing
in the better sense you have of yourself
the better you're gonna be as surviving
so just from that lens I mean the
evolutionary advantage of consciousness
or like introspection is that you get to
like optimize your own problem-solving
mechanism what we are talking about
though is the anthropocentrism and
Chalet argue said that that's a good
thing and he and he says that at the end
of the anima Kunz talk he says that
there's no such thing as artificial
general intelligence all intelligence is
specialized and human intelligence is
very specialized I mean Chalet gives
examples of we're surprisingly good at
doing things like the Traveling Salesman
problem on a small number of cities but
if you flip that on its head and you do
the opposite which is to find the
longest part suddenly humans are really
bad at that
we could at solving spatial problems in
3d but we can't see them in 4d so we
think of our own intelligence as being
incredibly general but it's not we
should delude ourselves the domain of
that activity is very very truncated to
the kind of problems that we might
encounter and if you if you define
system to tasks as anything where you
have to expend mental effort that is I
mean it's a it's a clearly human centric
of looking at the world but I'm fine
with that as well because after all it's
a practical solution right well ok let's
say like mammal where you do like
gradient through gradient so you have
like the gradient of the inner loop and
the gradient of the outer loop do you
think those two things become so
intertwined that could be where
consciousness comes out of with like
sufficient capacity in it complex tasks
and complex representations like because
they start to become entangled I totally
agree that like the intelligence doesn't
need to have consciousness I really
don't like this post dichotomy of system
1 and system 2 what we seem to agree on
is that system 2 allows us to take
shortcuts and because we have the mental
apparatus in our brains it means that
the shortcuts are appropriate in certain
circumstances why could we not replicate
that in a
neural network is it just because they
don't have the architecture or mechanics
to take those shortcuts because there
are loads of shortcuts on system 1d
planning models they that's that's why
it's so difficult to create a benchmark
of artificial intelligence because there
are so many shortcuts you can take
especially if you have a fairly fixed
task that you're performing a recent
paper is like early exiting and question
answering systems what they get to like
layer four of the Bur model and they're
like oh our confidence is high enough
we're not even going to go through
layers five through eight so we're just
gonna exit and predict earlier you mean
that sense that like we can predict
quicker and distill how quickly we're
confident about our prediction and exit
are like processing of what we're gonna
predict if I mean assistant to system
would be able to make to come up with
that idea by itself right because right
now the humans the humans go and say
well I need a new research paper and why
don't I just do this thing and then yeah
but so the human here is the system two
thing that comes up with the idea of
doing this at layer 4 right and I think
Tim you said it very wealthy that the
fact that there are shortcuts in any
individual task is different from what
we actually want what we actually want
this we can't really describe it but
it's something with generalization it's
something with forgive you something new
you should be able to find the shortcut
as fast as possible
exactly I just want to quickly touch on
something else as well so in the in
industry people are always talking about
explain ability and it's something I
really like about Ben geo is he's made
it clear that a lot of knowledge cannot
be verbalized and that one-liner I think
is beautiful because as Yannick was
saying the other week explain ability
methods are a bit like reading tea
leaves and one of the things I'm
interested in is is I believe that
machine learning is the next generation
of software engineering I'll hold my
hand up and I'll say it's not
intelligence these are these are
programs their skill programs some of
them are written using code these new
machine learning skill programs
generated from data and we don't
understand how they work but they are
programs nonetheless but these things
need to be put into production and
there's a lot of people saying we need
to understand their behavior why don't
we just attack there are gradations
right so the data scientists when
they're creating the model maybe they
should do some interactive explain
ability stuff just to check that it's
not doing something perverse so if
you're detecting I don't know lions or
something you should make sure that
you're not looking at where the grass is
you're looking at where the lion is but
once this becomes an engineering
pipeline you should be testing you
should be doing data grouping and
semantic counterfactual examples and
you're doing things that can be
automated
these explained ability methods of the
elephant in the room here is that deep
learning models do not generalize they
only have local minimal generalization
that depend on having a dense sampling
in the input space so they only
generalize insofar as they interpolate
between the dense sampling of trainer I
think it ties back to this idea of
systemic generalization and then
particularly taking apart the kinds of
generalization that we are interested in
so a one paper squinting at virtual
question-answering models it says the
question is is the banana ripe enough to
eat so this systemic generalization is
about the compositionality of that
question and it also answer are the
bananas mostly green or yellow so it's
like I agree like these tests of
explained ability I think it should be
tests on like treating it like a black
box or another black book like what kind
of generalization are we after exactly I
think is important with that yeah that's
a great example so I think that I would
call those logical consistency rules and
so they are great ways to test the
robustness sonic model because we need
to accept that these models do not
generalize that's the whole point they
do not generalize and that's why we need
to have some kind of mixture of symbolic
and and and deep learning models and we
need to have a rigorous testing
procedure can we agree that if I build a
explainable model and it can tell me in
language why it made a certain
classification which is like the holy
grail of the exploit
ability crowd is still not system to I
think it doesn't that's what's so
beautiful about what benzio says some
knowledge is not verbalize oh yeah I'm
not sure let's let's play with it this
why why are you not sure I think if you
give me a time I can verbalize pretty
much any of my subconscious knowledge
Wow I think I disagree verbalize why and
you say imagine your brain was actually
ten times bigger than it was at what
point which you stop saying that you can
verbalize what's going on I also think
you're not taking account how fine-grain
this subconscious knowledge Excel play
it's a shooter basketball apply exactly
eighty Newton's of force in your tricep
like the exact force and like how to see
a cat would be like do this exact thing
in your brain that's ultimately Alan
Turing's contribution to say look any
sort of function can be computed with
the bands described in a series of bits
right with a bit string and if what I'm
doing is computing a function I can
describe it with a bit string and
therefore with language okay yeah
okay so then maybe the question is
searching for that bit string is gonna
be intractable though absolutely I'm not
I'm not saying that but I have I am
taking issue with the fact that the
system to system one distinction can be
made with verbalize ability what maybe
you can say is that system terminology
is one where I have to verbalize right
system one knowledge is I can just let
it run if I want to I don't have to I
don't have to verbalize it but I can
yeah I struggle with that because I
think there are many things which are
ineffable I mean hypothetically speaking
if you were to some psychedelic and you
experience things where there were no
human words to explain what you are a
means to start but that's good first and
there are so many examples of things
that exist outside of our domain of
understanding is inside our domain of
common understanding we place anchors
and those anchors are words
what about all of the things that are
outside of that domain of understanding
well I can just describe with words if
there's not no word I can use other
words to describe the thing like there's
a beautiful paper just came out
yesterday or it like a github project
where someone trained GPT to on a
dictionary and it can make new words and
it can make up like explain I can I can
be like a mathematician I just defined
the new word and explained with using
other words what the new word means and
then I'm good to go
do you think that'll be a good tool for
like like I sound like the MENA chatbot
made that joke where the horse went to
haver write that like this joke that the
bike parent coding had learned to put
hay and bird together and make this joke
that a horse goes to haver instead of
Harvard do you think that this word does
not exist kind of dictionary of made-up
words could be a way for explain ability
with different segments of the word
embeddings there's a nice question yeah
let's play this it makes sense you know
this person does not exist so you take a
whole space of known people and you can
interpolate between them and create
people that don't exist anymore the
whole point of language is to provide
reference points semantically relevant
reference points to our shared
understanding of our reality I don't
think the analogy works it doesn't it
doesn't mean anything to invent a word
but any thing that I would describe and
insist some knowledge that I would have
would be part of our reality and
therefore at least within the convex
hull of the words that we have but that
would mean that the meaning itself would
also be some kind of interpolation
between the words that you used to
create the new word so you haven't
really created anything new semantically
but but it's just because we don't have
a word to describe something as long as
it's in the convex hull of other words I
can either use these other words to
describe it or I can just make up a new
word and define it and then use that so
just because we don't have a word to
describe something doesn't mean we
cannot verbalize it
that's true but there is a space of
concepts in reality that map to the
convex hull of words that we know and
you are still not getting any closer to
describing things outside of that convex
hull
but you first have to show me that the
system while knowledge is outside of
that convex hull which I don't believe
because it's part of our reality
so we ought to have words for it
well on the topic of is this explainable
like one example so david ha played a
fit and then he goes by the twitter
handle hard maru right and the word came
up with a definition for this is an
intense heat especially as caused by
burning or burning is how it talks but
like that doesn't make hard maru an
intense heat
that's not explainable where does the
interpolation come even it's not like
you can tell with this tool specifically
you know i mean but if i define that
word right if i want to transmit that
information i could define that word as
the intense heat it doesn't mean we have
to like come to the same conclusion but
if i define it and then we both accept
that definition we can communicate with
it I mean I'm just I'm just not buying
there you you can't verbalize system one
things I like the idea of you have to is
that the distinction is that you have to
verbalize it but that kind of goes back
to embodiment in that in the site that
all this multi-agent system so that's
kind of my idea that consciousness
system too is a product of all of us
together yes that's the only system but
then you also use it internally because
if we think in language - yeah so so
another another inconsistency with with
this is the example that Benja makes is
a system to knowledge can become system
one knowledge right if I repeat the task
that I have to spend mental effort on
over and over again it becomes system
one knowledge that doesn't mean I
suddenly cannot verbalize it anymore
just because it became a system one task
we say that it's AI if we don't
understand it yet and again you're gonna
get pissed off with me constantly citing
chalette that I love him there's
something he talked about in his paper
called the the McCord
there's guy called McCord duck and he
had this thing called the AI effect
where the goalposts move every time
progress and AI is made so every time
someone figures out how to do something
like makers computer played checkers
there'll be a chorus of critics that say
that's not thinking so as soon as we
understand what it is then it's not
thinking anymore
and I would say it's the same thing for
system-to-system - is like the bit that
we don't understand so we're calling it
system - when we actually make that
state and I don't think it's any
different to what we're doing now then
it won't be system 2 anymore it would
just be the same as everything up well
it's it's not the fault is with the
people that claimed it was thinking in
the first place right the fault is with
the people that said once we solve
checkers we have something intelligent
like no like the default clearly lies
there but it's at least I I think so I
would not I would not know of a task
even where I said once we solve that we
have built something intelligent when
the priors could help extend deep
learning incorporate the kind of sure
that exists for these four concepts and
system two tasks one of the first priors
that I'll talk about in my presentation
is regarding the structure of the Joint
Distribution between those people let's
call them semantic variables the Joint
Distribution can be described by a
graphical model in particular a factor
graph which is sparse meaning that the
pieces of knowledge
each involved very few variables in
addition those variables are often have
something to do with causality they are
about agents they're about intentions or
actions and they're about controllable
objects another hypothesis that I almost
already gave you earlier is that there's
a simple relationship between those
high-level variables and arts or phrases
though there is a simple relationship
between conscious thoughts and words and
sentences in general we can express our
conscious thoughts what assumption that
I won't have time to talk a lot about
but is very clear for example in
programming or in logical thinking
is that those pieces of knowledge can be
reused think of them as rules that could
be applied across many instances which
you can think of those like arguments of
functions and because of this this
system to computation can deal with
variables and indirection very important
point about that of variables is how it
changes over time how the distribution
changes over time and tell you later
about those distributional changes which
we're going to assume are due to causal
interventions and because of this they
involve local change in in the structure
of the Joint Distribution maybe just one
buyable has changed one condition has
changed and that only works because
those variables have a causal semantics
so it's connected to this earlier prior
that I mentioned in addition when there
is a change in the solution most of the
rest of the Joint Distribution doesn't
change as well as the relationship
between our observations sensory data
low-level actions and the high-level
variables so the only thing that changes
when there's an intervention is from
property or some values of higher
variables but not their relationship to
perception finally their assumption that
I won't have time to talk much about is
about how we reason and plan and do
credit assignment with respect to these
variables so the the Assumption here is
that credit assignment only involves
short causal change at each and we do
such a credit assignment so these shared
rules tuples I assume he means a little
bit like knowledge graphs again where we
have a subject and predicate and an
object and those rules can be shared
across multiple instances
are those rules learned are they fixed
or they static
that's a ghost good question probably
mix between pre programmed by evolution
and learned by yourself because if any
talks about credit assignment right and
that's that's mainly the learning part
so what he's talking about is they
thinks that you have these system one
systems that could whatever is the input
into this this farce factor graph and
the sparse fact graph basically it has
nodes that represent variables so
variable could be my house a ball job my
future as piece of wood but but also
with more abstract things and the these
nodes are connected by so called factors
and the factors just specify how the
nodes relate to each other and I think
later it gives the example if I drop the
ball it will fall to the ground so this
this very simple rule connects these
these factors and as that system to
operates in this space in this space of
these abstract concepts that somehow are
sparsely connected to each other with
these rules and how do you go from let's
say we have an image you need to get the
semantic information out of it it might
have a dog in it might have a tennis
ball in it does that just mean that we
have a neural network object detector to
pull the semantic information now before
it goes into this bus back to ground yes
that's happening that's basically what
he's what he's saying is that you
basically have a an encoder I think
that's even a slide that comes up we
have an encoder that you can think of
much like whatever your image net ResNet
50 and you just put all that's coming in
through your eyes you put that through
the encoder and then you have the high
level representation and a high level
representation now this is your your
concept variable so there you'll see a
dog and now your consciousness basically
operates only in the space of dog and
doesn't operate in the space of pixels
the only problem with this is back in
the days
factor graphs and probabilistic
graphical models the graph itself was
handcrafted by a human so the human will
he say there's this latent variable this
represents a dog or a Geoffrey Hinton
when he was talking about a casual
networks it was the ability to learn
semantic information in a way that could
be invariant to different transformation
of the image but what I would like to
see is some way of being able to
understand what the semantically
relevant information is without having
to hand code it yeah I mean that the the
crux of the method here is going to be
this sparsity because we don't for only
know how to learn things that are fully
connected in our machines we don't know
yet which of these variables connect to
which other variables right so what we
do is we do whatever your soft attention
we connect everything to everything in
an assign higher/lower ways and what
he's talking about is this farce factor
graph native only will ever work if this
is sparse and we don't know how to learn
sparse things well what do you think
about it like when you have the
generator model that goes from the
random sample disease into generated
images then you can start to label the
images so it's like a supervised
learning way of disentangling the
representations from the z space so
we're taking all these generated images
and we're gonna say we're gonna label
them an hour and say these are the
images where the face image the guy has
glasses on so start to cluster the Z
find all the Z's that produce glasses
and we'll label them for you so now what
I think you can do you keep doing that
glasses hat beard on all these little
features and now you have them in the z
space you know which areas of the z
space are causing these different
factors so maybe now you could come up
with an interpolation of the Z concepts
easier you have this kind of graph of
this you know there's overlap probably
in the Z's too it's not so here's this
node that is all the basis vectors and
they're so different from the Hat
vectors seem like they're not
you know isolated from each so do you
think that kind of supervised learning
of the to try to figure out which Aziz
produce which images is that kind of a
close idea to this factor graphic so you
here you're talking about gents right so
where you go from like a latent vector
into a let's say pixel space in terms of
images and then you classify that pixel
space your hypothesis here would be that
our this encoder thing that map's the
low level to the high level
representation actually comes about by
us having an internal generative model
of the world because that's basically my
translation of what you're saying is
that what we do internally is we say
okay
faced with glasses with hat that looks
about like this and then because we can
do that we can then again map it back to
the to the basal high-level space that
isn't entirely possible that is a
hypothesis we don't know if our
processing comes from generative
modeling the data or purely
discriminative modeling but the
generative model hypothesis would
explain for example why you're so good
at recognizing out of distribution
samples because with a generative model
you get that for free you can simply say
this data point it doesn't fit into any
of my classes right into any of my data
whereas if you were just a
discriminative machine you would not you
would not do that and the second thing
you say is also super super important I
actually agree with you in that Vendrell
says is there are these nodes so it says
these latent space is more or less a
discrete space right so you have dog
here and you maybe have fur and fur is
somehow connected to dog but it's still
it's it's entities this is a hypothesis
the other hypothesis would be look this
is all continuous this is all a
continuous space of things and you can't
really map this to these two these
single variables it's very interesting I
don't know I mean just from the
perspective of trying disentangle
factors
I think that the generative model is at
least the best way to interpret it and
make progress on it as we get to look at
it yes are you suggesting
Jannik that our conception of reality
the way we perceive that we live in is
one big hallucination maybe that's how
you learn it right maybe the way you
learn high-level representation is just
by trying to reconstruct reality in it
from your brain right so that means you
you come up with a set of with a
hypothesis of these latent over latent
variable and then you reconstruct and if
it fits right then you know ah this is
the correct high level representation
this is a completely different
hypothesis from saying something like
you have a four word function a
classifier that just takes pixels and
gives you high level representation it's
completely different because with one
your your ability to do that comes from
your ability to generate right and that
that's something like that Hinton would
say it is basically saying what we're
doing when we do object recognition is
we do an inverse render but we can align
our latent model of the world with what
we're seeing but then Joe leaves this
away when Joe just says do you have some
sort of encoder I gives you this high
level representation but maybe we can we
can connect the notion of continuity
that you said with these variables but
it's very hard what you somehow have to
say is that yeah it's very it's very
hard I'm trying to connect the fact that
these latent spaces appear to be
continuous but Ben Joe says something
about sparse discrete objects and that
doesn't really bring to me except maybe
if your discrete space is super high
dimensional and every entry is one of is
a probability for one of these factors
but I don't see that generally the high
level representation is is not super
high dimensional so and and then he says
it's sparse which means that if now I
imagine I have a small dimensional
vector
and each of then that somehow represents
those variables if they're sparse that
means they must be independent so now I
have two few dimensions to represent all
these variables so either it can't be
sparse or it can't be discrete or it
can't be continuous in the way that we
perceive the world with the vector
quantized variation auto encoder that
powered like the opening I do box they
have the discrete codebook and then
they're sparse based on the higher and
they share this discrete code at the top
and then as they go down the hierarchy
of discrete codes at each level the
higher like this is sparse imperative
that go into the truth okay
so that could be an example of a
discrete latent code I don't think
anyone has done a discrete latent again
but I can see it working in the same way
maybe wonderful question is whether or
not that will lead to a sparse factor
graph over these codebook entries right
even though now it's discrete but we
still have a neural network that
basically connects every bar entry in
the code book to every other entry right
the complexity arises from us being able
to connect everything with everything
whereas Benjo says nice farce we only
should ever ever should come up with
rules that connect two or three of those
things and I don't think that we know
how to do that yet so he hasn't given us
any indication on how this sparse factor
graph comes in to exist it's just a
concession and the other thing that can
send me a little bit when you were
talking about that the human brain it's
very dangerous
this kind of anthropomorphize ation of
deep learning concepts because you were
talking about a representation what does
that even mean that the human brain do
we need representations these signals
just go to the relevant parts of the
brain and they just they just activate
the the regions do we need to have a
compressed representation in the same
way as a deep learning model did does it
even make sense to make that there is
wrong the neuron firing pattern is then
essentially a representation right so
then and there in the firing pattern and
that is certainly lower dimensional than
the number of concepts you can express
that's what I mean so your nor I can
describe your neuron firing pattern with
fewer numbers than the number of
concepts you can think of because the
the number of concepts you can think of
is addressed combinatoric lee by mixing
different neurons but what I'm saying is
there's a difference between signaling
and representations well I can redefine
I see what I see what you're saying yeah
it's it's there there's a difference
between like a hard core like a hard
representation where it can pinpoint
like here in the brain is the
representation and me saying that you
know just kind of the activation pattern
in the brain is the representation but
it leads to the same end thing somehow
we need to tell the brain what's going
on but in this high level
yeah it's it means I think he has a
slide on this later where he explains it
more closely I mean just like that it
just basically means very little well
here's why I like to generate or model
so much and exploring the latent space
for these factors that then change so in
this latent space Z even in like a style
game you can that's train on faces only
you can find a car in that late in space
like there's papers that find all the
images in that latent okay we can use
supervised learning to get the glasses
in the Hat and the beard clusters and
now we have the car now we give it car
like does this cluster still make sense
so we have this cluster that's doing the
Z's and we've attributed that to glasses
now that the Z's are general now that we
found the Z's that generate cars like
this overlap I think you know the idea I
can see some something where you'd say
ah here is a cluster even though I've
only trained on faces I can kind of sort
of produce a car right I can I can I can
do this with Dizzy's over here and then
if you really learn about cars
your entire model now changes as well so
that maybe these these latent
representations become more probable and
so on I mean I see what you're saying
and it's very plausible that by
basically having this generator and
going from the latent space to the real
world we learn about concepts you know I
can get on board with that maybe a
better example would be if we're trying
on only like male faces and then we have
a woman face with glasses and we can
stand that glasses Z vector is still the
same so now we're producing we found the
area of the z space is producing women
and then the glasses part of the Z
vector is has a high overlap maybe at
least not not in terms of consciousness
or anything but what he's saying with
the robustness to distributional changes
and the rules stay the same and so on
that might be a good example of what
he's talking about basically saying that
glasses on a glasses on one type of face
are still glasses on the other type of
face and you should use the same
components
your generator to produce these classes
well it's an interesting point right I'm
pretty sure gas that exists today can do
this glasses thing like that we have
Gans now that can modulate independent
factors and you can transfer these
independent factors to other things that
you've never seen before this is all
possible it is not system to by any
definition we've had so far
so this is it's all kind of mixed here I
did say it's all system one because
ultimately we just build one neural
network one forward pass boom it just
doesn't make sense to me though because
as we were talking about last week we're
talking about models that have almost no
generalization learning fixed manifolds
for particular types of semantic
informations we build a fixed factor
graph how is that making progress or
generalizing it what's what's clever
about that it seems like it's a fixed
prior that has been created by humans so
far we've so that's talking about system
to generalize that's the three
combinations and system to world so now
let's talk about what is maybe the most
interesting property assistant to
condition and that is the ability to do
what is called systematic translation
this is something that was studied a lot
in linguistics where humans can
dynamically we combine existing concepts
to form new concepts the verbal but it
could be visual like in this example
from Lake at all where different types
of vehicles are combined to form a new
one what's interesting is that
recombination allows us to explain
observations that we not only we have
never seen but they have zero
probability under our training
distribution like if I tell you a
science fiction scenario or you're
driving in the unknowns and unknown city
where the drive is very different up to
now what we have observed experimentally
a number of papers is that when they are
such changes in this fusion
the planning system don't perform very
well and they tend to overfit to the
training distribution not just training
data and so you have issues of transfer
that doesn't work as well as what humans
seem to be able to do I just disagree
here even when new combinations have a
zero probability under the training
distribution like driving in an unknown
city like that it just I mean you have
to define your training distribution so
surgically to make that happen to make
the probability zero
you basically have to say you're only
allowed to train in this one it's a
forceful reduction of your training
distribution to that that driving in an
unknown city has a zero probability I am
see I just take issue with this zero
probability thing and then the fact that
that should be something special because
let's make the assertion that the
training distribution for any computer
vision data set it's combinatorially
large you would never ever have anything
that even approaches a representative
silo of the distribution but it is hard
to come up with an image that has a zero
probability under my training
distribution almost any image will have
a close to zero probability but some
zero like and I don't I don't see what's
so special about having things having a
zero probability under the training
distribution now what I can what I can
see here is that the basically talks
about okay if there's distribution shift
then humans tend to adapt more quickly
and better than current machine learning
systems which is true
but I suppose what he's saying here is
that you can build models to learn some
kind of first-class semantic objects in
your images so motorcycles people
scooters unicycles
so rather than capturing the combination
in system one it's almost like you break
it up into intermediate steps so you
capture the primary colors or the first
class citizens in system one and then in
system two you do the recombinations so
we have supervisors we have our bike and
we have the different Z factors that
produce bikes right maybe the system too
is then distilling the different factors
into the this guy on this unicycle
motorcycle it's like that's the system
to part I guess is what I think he's
saying is that system one we produce
these you know we have disentangled
representations of this I think there's
a Segway and then a buy a motorcycle and
in a unicycle so and then combining the
disentangled representations as a system
to thing it could be but again I asked
what's what's what is the probability
under your training distribution not
data set under your training
distribution of this monstrosity it's
not zero right I think it's back to just
the energy based models versus
probabilistic money doesn't isn't maybe
not the best thing to be trying to push
things to zero probability
[Music]
yeah I mean yeah I guess what is saying
is that the machines aren't yet very
good at doing this generalizing what
you're saying this recombination of
things that they know in unknown ways I
mean that's the best exciting for you
know Chalet talks about the four
different types of generalization
there's absence of generalization which
was the case in traditional expert
systems and then there's local
generalization which is what machine
learning does now so the ability for a
system to handle new points from a known
distribution for a single task or well
scoped set of known tasks given a
sufficiently dense sampling so that's
what we have now and what we want to
move to is this broad generalization you
know so that would be like there was
niak coffee cup a challenge where you
have a robot can go into any single room
and make a cup of coffee and I think
this is a step in that direction because
he's saying that you can find
combinations of semantic objects in all
likelihood let's just say it's zero
probability and all likelihood would not
have shown up in your training
distribution yeah but it's these
distinctions between local and spend
less local copy we're very close to
building a robot that can go into any
room and bring you a cup of coffee like
something go explore combined with some
model of predictive control it'll soon
be able to do that and the people will
say well that's just local
generalization right or even even expert
system see I can build an expert system
and then I can ask you to question that
not only has it not heard before that no
human has ever heard before and you can
answer it correctly and I so this this
kind of levels of generalization not
buying it it's just it's the same thing
it's just okay the scale is different
but well I think shalay would say that
there wasn't a coffee cup challenges
broad generalization you know the
ability to handle situations that could
not have been foreseen by the creators
of the system so if you think that we're
close to doing that then that is broad
generalization but again if you build an
expert system I can ask it a question
that you have not foreseen it
no human has foreseen it because no
human has ever thought of that question
and it can answer it correctly but the
difference is in the expert system you
could enumerate analytically the space
of possible questions and answers well
yes but in the space of robots coffee
cup gatherings
if you discretize the world to a
fine-grained grid you could analytically
enumerate the other possible things that
could happen there but that's not the
way that these control systems work
though they work by creating some kind
of representation which will have some
kind of generalization to difference if
you will do the expert systems they they
map your questions to a regular
expression it's not like they have all
the questions and answers as a lookup
table they map it to a representation
which is a regular expression and then
they do their logic rules with that and
then you get the answer to a question
you've never ever seen before or thought
before or thought of because my shoelace
is really skeptical about deep learning
he says that they're a bit like hash
tables deep learning is basically a hash
table tickly an expert system is in an
expert system you have regular
expressions for example which make a
useful representation of a string so if
you are being really cynical you could
say there's no difference at all between
the original expert systems and deep
learning not qualitatively no okay
either qualitative differences it's one
is learned maybe one is learn from data
or one one of the inputs to it is
training data but that's that's really
always telling programmers and what not
you still need priors you still need the
computer I don't I don't see really
qualitative difference and I'm not gonna
see a qualitative difference with
Wozniak's robot that gets me a coffee
cup well the regular expression mapping
is it's nowhere close as expressive as
these transformations and deep neural
networks sure the quantitative
difference is very apparent but the
qualitative difference I don't I don't
see you
I just generally in general I say only
the coffee cup example is very good for
generalization if you just show it
enough rooms it'll be able to get it I'm
not so sure about that it's not just
about the rooms though it's a little bit
like playing chess you would think is
really difficult if you ask someone in
the 70s what's harder you know playing
chess or picking up the telephone and
talking to your grandmother actually the
telephone one is harder because it's not
just about picking up phone it's about
all the natural language processing and
the speech recognition and God knows
what else
there are so many cognitive tasks that
would require specific skill programs to
implement you can transform the was near
exact it was it wasn't yak sorry I was
this okay yes so you can transfer this
example because he kind of leaves
himself a sneaky door opening daddy says
I should get me a cup of coffee whatever
happens in that room so you know if that
if that room there is like garry
kasparov there it's like good you play
me in chess right now reduces back to
general intelligence the robot and the
coffee cup is irrelevant it's just like
if I can put an IQ Mesa plate I can
construct a room with an IQ test and you
only get the coffee if you solve the IQ
test then so the example leaves leaves a
sneaky backdoor just reduces to a to a
GI or human level intelligence
well the qualitative difference from
deep learning to expert systems is that
I can do a PhD in deep learning all
right I'm very thankful for that cause
that leads into the symbolic AI program
the classical a I could old-fashioned AI
all together the best of both worlds we
want to avoid the pitfalls of
classically I will base Maalik
manipulation it keeps all the things we
have achieved with deep learning up to
now so efficient large-scale learning
semantic grounding in system one
presentation all of that implicit
knowledge I talked about we want to keep
this representation for example stables
would be represented by vectors
so that we get personalization and we
won't search which is something that
mostly happens on system to side to take
advantage of the power of system 1 to
guide the search and thus to be
efficient and finally of course one of
the advantages of modern machine
learning that we want to keep is the
ability to handle uncertainty properly
but while some of the advantages that
are associated with the system - I
mentioned system electrolyze asian it's
connected to a knowledge representation
idea that knowledge can be factorized
and host into small exchangeable pieces
in that manipulate variables instances
references and indirection one of the
important messages of this talk is that
in the last year's in deep learning we
have made progress with tools such as
soft attention which might be a
transition from the old deep learning
where we process vectors fixed size
vectors to this extended deep learning
which we actually manipulate stuff I
think at least to the to the need
uncertainty handling point of this I
don't I agree
I don't think humans do that well I
don't think humans handle uncertainty
well so if we're talking about human
level intelligence that's not something
we need buddy it would be nice to have
and here he talks a lot about search
that he wants most of this search to
happen in a system - and that brings me
back to the to the beginning almost in
that he seems to view system 2 as
something where you'd have to perform
some kind of manual labor manual mental
labor spend effort to do a a search in
this in this kind of space of these
latent variables so he's almost like you
have to go step by step by step and do
this manual search down a logic tree
until you find something like ah this is
how you get
how I get to my goal right and each of
the each of the steps in the search tree
is something that system one could
handle but it can't jump to the solution
I think this some somewhat becomes clear
here that system two can be
conceptualized as searching when right
when when you don't know yet where you
want to go and but you want this to be
guided by system one and your the
analogy that could be made is maybe
something like alphago where you have
you could train an RL algorithm that
will just it's just in reinforce policy
gradient and every here's a board
situation this is what you're gonna do
but this will not work as well as if an
AI algorithm that can do the search
so yeah what if I do this what if I do
that and after that what if I do that
and so on you go down this tree but we
can't go down the whole tree because
it's too large so we use deep learning
we use the neural networks to guide this
search to say which are the which are
the mental steps that we need the the
elements of our plan that we need to
explore or that are promising to explore
next and that is informed by your
intuitive system 1 thinking so I think
this it just makes it a bit more clear
what he sees as these two systems and
where he sees them connected and I
mostly agree actually with this kind of
thinking yeah I think you nailed it with
the Monte Carlo tree search alphago
comparison to because at each you know
the Monte Carlo tree search it looks for
the best action and then as it puts out
all these potential next nodes to go to
and then it uses intuition or its policy
and value networks to choose which one's
of those to go to next so I think that's
just the perfect analogy for describing
that
it says need efficient large-scale
learning isn't that an oxymoron
large-scale learning means sample
inefficient brute-force learning with
millions and millions of iterations
isn't that the antithesis of efficiency
isn't that what we want to get away from
maybe what he what he means is that you
need a way to efficiently learn from
large data like I've been like younger
car so I think maybe he's referring to
so what the title is we want to avoid
pitfalls of classical a I you know
rule-based systems and these these would
these would be very expensive to compute
and therefore if I want to learn and
classical AI system from data I have to
do this expensive computation because
that's basically the forward pass of the
model and that would not work well with
large data sets so he basically says we
we want something that is able to
incorporate large amounts of data and
this connects well to what Jung Lacan
said when basically the future is self
supervised in that system one here could
be a system that consumes this large
amount of data and kind of Tunes this
intuition to the large amounts I'm sorry
I think it's just saying that we need a
system that is able to do these kinds of
things these search and computation BOTS
can handle lots of data but some deep
learning is not efficient even with the
self supervised stuff it doesn't do
anything to address the sample
efficiency of deep learning he also says
that we need district representations
for generalization again as we were just
saying deep learning models do not
generalize that's the whole problem they
have minimal generalization given a
dense sampling of the infant space so it
seems to me that he's talking about the
pitfalls of the classical symbol based
manipulation if anything these are the
advantages for the classical space
manipulation what we want with system
two is the ability to learn quickly
think slowly but learn quickly and we
want to
representations that generalize well we
don't have that with deep learn that is
that is true I agree with Benja we
probably need distributed
representations for generalization
because the alternative would be to to
have basically point wise representation
right the unique representation and not
distributed once and for generalization
if you if all of your space is separate
and discrete you have almost no chance
of generalizing you only get that with a
distributed representation and then yeah
that the large-scale learning you're
right I I think if you were to question
him on that he might also I'd be very
surprised if his opinion was that we
need lots of data to learn the system
two tasks maybe what he means is that
the system one task that informs the
system two tasks can handle lots of data
not sure I mean another thing is it says
needs uncertainty handling now again
this is a maybe this is a trick question
but do you think probabilistic graphical
models are symbolic rule-based
programming I would argue they are in
which case you can do uncertainty
handling humans don't have good
uncertainty handling deep learning
doesn't have good uncertainty handling
and the fact that in a graphical model I
can kind of compute the uncertainty
accurately is counteracted by the fact
that I have to create the graphical
model from my mind like I put it down I
impose the structure of the graphical
model so the map the the accuracy of
that uncertainty is going to depend on
how much that structure fits with
reality and I would I would say you
probably have no chance no better chance
that your uncertainty there is your
actual uncertainty in the real world
than with a deep learning model just
because you can put a number on it
indeed I do agree with benzio though
that this notion of once you have a
factor
off with these semantic variables in you
can have this recombination than you can
just systematic generalization that
seems logical to me and I agree the
factorizing knowledge into small
exchangeable pieces course seems
completely reasonable to me
but how do you do that he hasn't really
given us any indication on how we would
create these factor graphs
programmatically I don't think he ever
completely do CRM for misunderstood is
presently he talks about given a fixed
factor graph which he's created himself
you can learn about the causality
between them based on the convergence
behavior that's completely different to
how do I get this factor graph in the
first place oh yeah yeah that's that
they're reversed back to what we talked
about before that if you want the sparse
thing we have no idea of how to learn
this well I don't know if I've sold you
guys on this yet but the idea of looking
in the late in space was something that
is supervised there semi-supervised
learning I think that really would
produce some kind of causal graph in
that Z space and I think you could
discretize the z space to some level not
you know not super really super fine
grain but yeah but is it sparse that's
that's the question right great because
we only know how to learn fully
connected things and especially like we
can we can like quantize and trim and
prune after the fact but we can learn
sparse things like from the get-go and
the question is clearly if what benjoe
says is true we must be able to directly
learn a sparse factor graph because it's
just too high dimensional it's like we
can't have every variable connected to
every other at the beginning and then I
know babies have more connections and
stuff but still that's I call our anger
level I don't follow you on that is why
could we not learn how to prune I mean
but what I'm saying is that in order to
prune you first have to have a fully
connected graph of what Benjo says is
true is true that we basically operate
in the space of these disk
concepts of which there must be common
like many many many right and that that
works if there are many many many as
long as they're sparsely connected but
we cannot it's not physically possible
to learn a fully connected graph between
them and then prune because we don't
have space for a fully connected graph
yes this is like the the catch-22
situation with the lottery ticket
hypothesis is that you you need to start
with the big one and then go down but
unfortunately it kind of defeats the
purpose don't know how to learn sparse
things because at some point you have to
connect the thing to the thing because
you make a new experience you connect
these two things but you don't what you
don't want is to what we do right now in
neural networks with especially with
things like attention we connect
everything to everything with a really
low weight and then you know the
gradient tells you put it up a bit yeah
I mean we didn't be learning about if we
did it any other way
yes because hard zeros aren't amendable
to gradient descent so yeah I'm saying
we have no to love how to learn sparse
things I like your idea of this and and
I'm not saying I agree with enjo that
this is the situation that that this
farce factor graph because I see the
problem
we do have continuous representations
for for because we're able to
interpolate what you're saying we have
this late in space and so on we could
discretize it but sparse so we're
talking about learning to prune so
starting big and getting smaller can't
we do the reverse can't we start not
infinitesimally small but small with a
dense sampling and learn to grow so you
mean you are dynamically add these
concerts the variables yes start with
something which is densely connected
enough to have a great gonna be learn
the pool and then build it out and
progressively so when you when you would
learn something in banjos version you
would only have very few of those nose
so initially you would only know about
dogs and cats and not about the rest of
the word
you add things I mean that's possible
but still if you add a new thing
what are you connected to
and at some point you need to revise
these connections how are you gonna do
that without iterating through each pair
of connections doesn't this get to the
elephant in the room which is that it's
not learn about if you want to have this
kind of semantic world view model it's
just not learn about well humans are
learning it so somehow it must be
possible so far maybe I'm not
technically seeing how one could learn
something but like what Ben Jo's
proposing if it has he has the three
attributes discrete sparse and
independent that's means the same as
first but yeah that that is it's it just
don't go with each other what I'm
reaching for something here but in our
poet algorithm and the environment start
to get more complex and it's not through
gradient descent would you say like okay
so these complex environments they start
simple I think Tim is really on
something with this idea of like maybe
like the neuro evolution of augmenting
topologies where they start off with
like one node and they evolve the
structure so the complex environment
that arises at the end of that maybe
this is what's happened maybe there's a
coevolution between the dense
representations and the sparse thing and
they kind of interact in a similar way
as our bipedal controllers and then the
environments this is the thing learn the
dense thing is what's using grady
descent this is using just evolution
search these know gradient descent
techniques yes but that that would mean
you could do the dense thing only ever
in a very small subspace of the of the
sparse thing right I think this just
this as possible this could be a way
that you basically are revising this
part of the sparse graph and then this
part and then this part yeah I can see
something like this which one of you is
going to pit it and change your PhD to
this new research idea which reminds me
we should do an episode in the future
about for your respective research
topics I think that'll be interesting
yeah I think the coevolution of sparse
and dense accident there could be
something really interesting about
I actually had a few like a few things
we've been talking about and trying to
think of how I could write a paper about
that well I've been I've been wanting to
do sort of strange research for a while
like okay I I do a PhD and I need to
write these papers and I'm kind of
relying on no one scooping me so I can't
really share my process but once I'm
done with this if we're never gonna
write in paper I'm gonna stream the
process or at least make a video
continuously about the facts like here's
my idea bla bla bla bla bla bla someone
scoops me who cares right I mean that's
but I I think it would just be so much
more fruitful to share this with this
process with the community and maybe a
new way of research can be or probably
not though because people are people
still have careers and stuff where they
need their name on things but it could
be really transformative because so many
people might transform your research
direction in real time or sanitation
system is ridiculous isn't it I've been
wanting to revise the scientific the
citation and publishing system for a
while okay
one of the important messengers of this
talk is that in the last few years in
deep learning we have made progress with
tools such as soft attention which might
be a key to a transition from the old
deep learning where we process vectors
fixed-size vectors to this extended
deepening in which we actually many
plates s can we harvest on a few
elements at a time
soft attention had a huge impact on
natural language processing starting
with machine translation allows us to
learn where to attend and interesting
neuroscience results suggest is
attention is like an internal muscle and
internal action and that is processed in
the brain in a similar way it allows
your less to operate on sense and it's
at the heart of several theories from
neuroscience about consciousness in
particular the global workspace theory
with respect to attention being present
in the brain I think that is certainly
correct and really important but also I
think that's not consciousness it might
be necessary for consciousness but just
because you have attention that have
consciousness to me consciousness might
arise from attend the attention
mechanism being able to attending itself
which we know ah and the question is is
that the consciousness or is that just
how a brain works without consciousness
oh there's attention needs to attend on
itself or does it just need to be one
hierarchy like this attention attends on
this attention and this Higher One is
the consciousness like do you think it
needs to be on itself or isn't this just
one step hierarchy enough for it to be
consciousness I would argue that deep
that the tension needs to be attending
itself because I can I can build right
now a system that has 50 layers of
attention and no consciousness but if
it's a meta learning system where the
outer loop is attending on the structure
of the inner loop and then they're
entangled in some way isn't that enough
still so I'm not gonna not gonna get
conscious anything conscious out of that
I don't think at least I think yeah well
I also think it has to arise out of a
very complex situation to the higher
dimensional the input the more diversity
I think that kind of complexity also
plays a role in like kind of this
attention - attention becoming very
expressive
maybe but if you if you look at the in
but it's not so high dimensional
honestly like you have vision that's
three channels you have audio that's one
channel you have tactile that's a couple
of channels you have olfactory that's a
few channels is lost
so I dimensional
maybe it is maybe it's possible but it's
definitely not possible now
right like to build a classifier you
know not even a reinforcement learning
system that operates on like 4k images
while simultaneously super high
resolution speech system maybe that is
what's gonna happen
maybe but you'd have to count on there
being like some sort of phase transition
once you get to a high enough
dimensionality and modality maybe I mean
maybe that's it's entirely possible
ultimately we're nothing more because
it's also a bit back to our coffee cup
thing like if you have enough
dimensionality I think it becomes like
this in really crazy compress event
compression engine then and it's also
like at the scale of the data it's seen
so many coffee cup rooms that it it can
figure it out what causes it to all of a
sudden go ah I've been seeing many
coffee cup rooms lately like the eye I
don't see that just a fact of scaling up
that eventually that would arise except
if you have attention attending itself
and that I see as a built-in feature and
not as something arising from from just
you know having higher-dimensional I
could be completely wrong here but but
don't you think we've already seen this
phase shift like just the fact that if
you give it a thousand Casarez dogs and
then compared to a million like haven't
we already seen that that exists
no my imaged my resonant is still not
telling me about itself
[Music]
but the phase shift idea with respect to
higher dimensional inputs and then more
data do you believe in that existing it
couldn't be like I had no clue right as
clueless as anyone about this but I I
just don't see that simply the act of
scaling up will all of a sudden
qualitatively shift the system from
interpolating the training data to
certainly becoming introspective about
itself and being able to express that
right I I think two things in climate I
think that with respect to scaling up
the interpolation just becomes so
powerful it becomes really hard to tell
the difference between that
interpolation and generalization but and
the next idea to explain it so that's I
think that's totally different and it's
a part of several theories from
neuroscience about consciousness learn
the global work space Theory copy or
Baibars that also by the hand and their
collaborators it involves the bottleneck
of conscious processing so information
is selected with attention from many
possible modalities and the input and
the selected items are then broadcast to
the rest of the brain as well as stored
in short-term memory to condition saying
perception and action in the short-term
and this enables sequential processing
conscious reasoning planning and
imagination one interesting thing to
note here is that if we think of the
brain particular core text as a big
simulation engine that enroll some some
kind of imagined future it does so in a
very special way it's not like a movie
it focuses on a few aspects movie at a
time at each step of this simulation so
it's not saying it explicitly here but I
think that is how system two interacts
with system one so it says nothing
particular about system two in fact
but it says something about so I think
the model is sort that he puts up here
sort of like the brain has the brain is
now operating in this logic space of
system - right and it has an object it
thinks about like a door so what it will
do is will broadcast through the rest of
the brain the distributed representation
of that dog and all the parts of the
brain will basically answer with with
what they know about this signal so your
glass I like dog dog dog dog and then
all of the your parts your memory or
your audio memory your tactile memory
and so on they will all send back what
they know and then this system - is some
are tasked with integrating that
information and then kind of going to
the next step of its logic processing it
tells us nothing much about how that
logic processing happens but I do I do
like the idea that this is how system to
interfaces with system one the system
one is the thing that would just send
back the information right given this
signal the thought occurs why have we
not tried to recreate something like
this using a neural network architecture
well maybe it's hard I think you
articulated beautifully what benzio was
talking about yeah and it made me think
that our brains are there's no nexus of
computation there are distinct systems
and there are broadcast and messages
that get sent between the systems and
possibly that the prefrontal cortexes is
the master mind that does some kind of
it maybe it has precedence over the
other systems but why have we not
created a neural network architecture
somewhat akin to that
why are there are architectures we
create are just very linear just left to
right there are things like memory
networks where you sort of store
information in this distributed way and
then retrieve it again but what you can
say it is drastically different for
example from a let's say a transformer
at
former you simply forward propagate your
input through the layers and the
knowledge about the world of the
knowledge about language is stored in
the connections between the layers like
in the weights
whereas this model would say something
like you here you are reasoning and then
you're retrieving information basically
from the rest of the brain by attending
to one particular part of the
computation that you would do so I think
it's you I mean you have a point maybe
we should go into building more of those
what's the difference between top-down
attention and bottom-up attention I
think if something is like bird is being
bottom-up attention in the sense that it
gets the input and it's like attention
attention attention
yeah maybe if you have like the features
that it's like CNN seeing it and
accomplished the layer accomplished
layer accomplished their attention that
sounds like top down to me well top
maybe I'm not sure but maybe top down is
something where we have it you know like
a sec to second our enemies so what you
would do is encode your entire input
sequence and then once you decode your
output sequence that's when you generate
the attention queries to go back to the
input sequence right so when you hear
but at that point topically you say all
I need to produce this thing here what
do I want to gather whereas yeah in burn
as you say you you always make the
attention from the input I mean
ultimately in the RNN it comes from the
input as well the the connection between
consciousness and language is very
strong in fact this is almost the way in
which we know that some event is
conscious which is unconscious and that
is that people can report it verbally
it's also important to understand that
we need to tie those high-level
representations with lower-level option
if we there's a lot of knowledge about
the world that cannot be represented
those strong assumptions talking about
and so in order to understand language
we need to have both kinds of knowledge
involved this gives rise to research in
things like grounded language learning
let me talk about this very basic yeah I
think I'm kind of worried that this idea
of grounding language and vision is
gonna be where I couldn't like academia
gets completely left behind me if now
they're built like this is gonna be to
me like this large-scale
kind of thing that this is where we'll
see the 100 billion parameter model is
something that's doing language and
vision simultaneously
yeah baby but maybe you can just you can
just take pre-trained these pre-trained
models on the data modalities and then
learn a system to on top of those them
no nowhere here does it really say you
need to learn them jointly let me talk
about this very basic prior in my list
which I called in 2017 the consciousness
prior the idea is that your Joint
Distribution of these high-level
variables is sparse so if you think of
the joint as represented by a factor
graph think of each factor involving a
few variables like a sentence what is
this there's an amazing property of
high-level language like this which is
that in a single sentence I can make a
probabilistic prediction that is very
strong that has a high probability of
being true in spite of the fact that it
involves very few variables so if I say
if I drop the ball it would fall on the
ground make a very strong prediction but
it involves only a handful of concepts
now this is different problem the common
assumptions of marginal independence
where we assume that higher variables
are independent that we have these
dependencies for example ball and hand
are not independent and this also
connects to the illusion of attention
that is talked about because when you
want to do inference over such a sparse
graph a reasonable way of doing it is to
focus on a one or a few factors at a
time just traveling in in that graph in
order to iteratively
some some inferences makes it makes a
lot of sense what what is saying it it's
just a question of first of all how do
you learn such a thing and second of all
how does that connect to the fact that
you have distributed representations
like this this is what I've been
criticizing sort of that it is really
distributed representation that appeared
to be sort of continuous how does that
connect with this very discrete sparsely
connected a thing I'm just I'm really
confused because he's talking about such
an abstract from
I have no idea how this factor graph
comes into existence I mean yeah I get
it you know that there are all these
semantic things inside your image and
you can disentangle the factors and you
can create this space factor graph to
model the Joint Distribution between
them and then you can do all sorts of
clever stuff but it's just how do you
get there I mean though you think like
overly simplified to the idea it's just
like an atomic all is a note on the
graph then like hand is this atomic
other note on the graph now I think
that's what he means that that is that
is in fact what what his idea is that
you have these objects and these objects
are sparsely connected with these
factors and so the the objects here are
all ground and in the hand or something
and the it the factor that connects them
is if you drop it then it falls on the
ground I mean would it be possible to
learn these factor graphs in a
supervised way so imagine if given a
whole bunch of problem so I tell you
what the factor graph is and then a new
unseen problem could I predict the
factor graph yeah I mean that's that's
this point right that somehow if this is
correct
somehow humans are able to learn this
factor graph and then when I you know
change one part of the factor graph
first of all all the others remain and
second of all the relationships still
remain so if I if I you know I get a new
idea of what a car is like okay there's
there's not this Tesla thing and it's
it's something completely different but
it's still a car I can just plug it into
the node for car and all my rules will
still apply right and if if if I learn
something about the car relationship of
cars like all we now drive left or right
whichever come to you like if that
changes then that applies to all the
cars including the test let's talk about
the assumptions regarding how things may
change in the solution this is a very
very important hypothesis that I think
provides some of the
great power of conscious processing so
the picture you should have in your mind
is this raw data which has a very
complex Joint Distribution we're gonna
represent it with two levels there's a
then quarter that Maps that raw data to
an abstract space these high-level
semantic variables and what happens when
there's a change in distribution
according to this hypothesis is that
that abstract space the change is
localized maybe just one variable
wanting to know one factor needs to be
modified consequence it becomes much
easier to learn without to the modified
distribution we should have fast
transfer you represent information in
the right way so that's basically saying
how could you attempt to learn such a
thing and that is the regularizer that
you die by so the regularizer is if
something changes in my input through an
action that I do or something then I can
only change one or two things in my
factor graph that's that's essentially
it's a regularizer
for learning such a thing and then also
for inference it's a it's a yeah
it's the implication that the encoder
creates the semantic variables or the
factor graph as well both yeah okay and
that's by some get the two an anaemic
probably the encoder and decoder creates
the encoder creates a representation and
then you have some way of mapping that
representation to the nodes in the
factor graph sorry yeah I mean I can
speak cannot speak for me because the
encoder ends up being totally
deterministic and it's latent variables
that are really the thing I think right
this is likely and very Moseman the
sparse factors and how do you
disentangle that I guess yes because he
also makes the comment on the slider
change may be drastic in pixel space but
tiny in the semantic space of causal
variable as well of course the whole
point of deep learning models is to give
you semantic information irrespective of
you know pletely normal changes in in
the environment or what but there's
comes back to this discreteness and and
and sparsity of the factor breath if you
if he would model consciousness as being
in distributed continuous space then he
could not make a thing like that well he
could that's basically what the
disentanglement crowd is saying the
disentanglement crowd is saying there is
this distributed continuous space that
you operate in and if you make a big
change to your input then only one of
the dimensions changes
benjoe here goes a step further and he
basically says there are these discrete
variables that are sparse to connect and
if I change a big thing only one of
those will change so it's the same thing
but in a discrete sparsely connected way
instead of in a continuous distributed
way so once you've disentangled the
factor is in the Z representation and
they're discretized well enough it
becomes like a super node so we have a
five dimensional vector and now it's
sparse such that we have one is like
taking on one of ten values so that's
like a note the littler node and then
and then say the fourth spot and this
five dimensional vector is taking on one
of ten values these are the two nodes
that make up this super node that's
connected to the other node so the idea
would be can we like take apart this
that nodes within the super nodes it's
kind of how I'm thinking about it yeah
oh yeah I kind of get but he makes it he
makes it explicit that what he's talking
about is not the same as this
entanglement because his factors can be
entangled but just sparsely and and
sparsely meaning also sort of
independently so it's not like there is
a rule to how the sparsity arises
because then that would limit your
capacity and the interaction effect yeah
the Z thing might have finally been
defeated
I'm just saying that's probably what
been Joe's thinking of but we actually
tried this idea in simple settings first
with variables a and B where you learn
through changes of distribution that
involve mention on one of the variables
and we find that the speed of learning
is a good clue for how you have the
right hypothesis the right set of
high-level variables and whether H to be
the causal B or B should be the cause of
a recently ended that word theory side
to prove and this notation also converge
to the the right hypothesis so extended
direction of log now this is where it
gets really interesting one of the key
problems with deep learning as cited by
the causality crowd is that there is no
way to tell if a causes B now let's make
this a bit more concrete so MBA
variables so you were saying a could be
a hand B could be a glass of water and
this corresponds to X's and Y's and we
can reformulate it in both directions
and so the first thing is how do we
disentangle a and B and the second thing
is once we've done that can we learn a
causal relationship and he seems to be
suggesting that by looking if you look
at the convergence behavior on the
training a to be converges much quicker
so we can infer from that that there's a
causal relationship I mean that seems
pretty interesting I mean what we know
is that ultimately we should get to the
same result because whether or not they
causes B or B causes a their correlation
is going to be the same and deep
learning will only ever you know focus
on the correlative aspect of data but I
think that's it pretty smart here I'm
pretty sure the causality crowd is kind
of on that is asking how easy is it to
learn a from B or B from a and here the
proxy we take is how many SGD steps are
something like this does it
with one model versus with the other
model I think that's quite small again
nothing to do with consciousness but
smart
are there any engineering pitfalls here
because just measuring the convergence
behavior is tricky there's so many
factors influence it and it would need
to be a fair experiment oh yes
especially automatically determining
this I mean that yeah it's surprisingly
difficult even to know when to stop
training or you know were to
characterize one convergence from
another is surprisingly difficult
yeah plus plus you you will have no you
will only have this graph but you can
only test these two directions in this
graph this says nothing about whether or
not that's the actual correct
arrangement of the graph whether there
is a variable C that is a confounder
that causes both a and B right even then
you're going to learn one direction
faster than the other it could still be
that there's a confounder that there's a
mediator that there's like a billion
other things in just in terms of
learning the causal direction I think
that's it's pretty smart Jeff would you
quantify this in a contrastive way or in
an absolute way so would you say that
this looks like a fast convergence in an
absolute sense or would you have more of
a comparative or relative thing because
as you say that the graph could be
significantly more complicated and the
more factors you have they would
probably flatten the convergence
behavior so you might need to have more
the contrastive approach if if you just
determined that this is the graph and
you just need to figure out which one is
the direction then you can do the
comparative the relative right just
which one's faster which ones above the
other after this many steps or generally
but if you if you're not sure that this
is the graph you have no chance quick
sidenote
with causality is it possible to have a
transitive causality so I do something
you know a causes B causes C could you
say that a causes C or is it only one
hop mean terminology wise so just
philosophically speaking
to have multiple factors you know P
could be caused by a EC and E yes so in
terms of in terms of do calculus
internal maybe you know Judea pearl
language you you might say that a causes
see in that because if you perform an
intervention on a that will cause the
distribution shift in C so that that
would be a causal relationship there but
you know that's that's an opinion and
the terminology in direction of larger
graphs are just two variables with the
fact that the number of such graphs is
exponentially large characterizing the
graph complete through its edges and I
don't that you can do fast cause of
discovery using this method cleared of
work right by just a double check what
exactly does it mean by factorize the
Joint Distribution does he mean make its
pass yeah it make make the causal graph
and make it sparse is a requirement such
that you can actually handle it to
engineering-wise you could factor as it
fully connected but I think he means in
a sparse way yeah so let's say we have
three variables X Y Z and the Joint
Distribution of they each take on say
three values so your factorizing is say
X is taking its third value how that
connects with Y second value and Z's
second value well factorizing in here is
equivalent to drawing the causal graph
and you generally assumed that these
calls will graphs are sparse because
like this this whole assumption of I
change one thing that's going to
influence the two next things and then
there's no direct so for example if
there's rain then that will cause my
roof to be wet and then that will cause
water to come down the drain right so
then we don't we don't need an arrow
from rain to water down the drain
anymore because we have an arrow from
rain to roof and from roof to drain
there is no additional causal effect
from the rain because we know the rain
is not gonna run around and go into the
drain from the bottom without first
hitting the roof so the kind of
assumption that this is sparse comes
from the causal structure of the world
generally being sparse but in terms of
factorizing just means drawing the
causal graph determining the causal
graph from data so sparse as in terms of
the cardinality of the values that each
variable can take on or sparse in terms
of connecting several variables in the
Joint Distribution yet the connections
are assumed to be sparse or yeah
generally sparse in the world
instead of work I want to mention it's
on some of these hypotheses in
particular the deposition of knowledge
into pieces that can be recombined
directly is all recurrent in mechanisms
where and we define a new current your
net architecture in which instead of
having a homogenius Network we break the
recurrent net into smaller modules where
inside each module it's fully connected
but between modules there is a attention
mechanism which you can think is where
consciousness is focusing that selects
which module is talking to which module
and module is sending value pairs
so essentially variables but name type
as well as value and find is that this
kind of architecture leads to better out
of distributional ization this it leads
to better out of distribution
generalization but less accuracy
probably I don't know but it's a cool
architecture but I guess it's not gonna
work as well for most problems yes since
this is an or an N like what it yeah
since this is an RN and what it does is
it kind of does some computation then
it's far suffice that computation and
here it's not the attention but indeed
I'm not sure if the attention it really
like this just bunches together a bunch
of things so it is in essence in
computation then it compresses and then
from that compressed representation it
takes the next inputs and does the
computation again so this can be akin to
the brain you know doing some reasoning
and then sending out getting information
computing that and doing some reason
anymore but it's very abstractly
connected to this and then the fact that
attention is used to send these things
around I mean fine but I don't I still
fail to see what that really has to do
with conscious not let me summarize and
conclude this brief talk I've tried to -
a direction of research for deep
learning
words capturing that just system one
fudge but also system to knowledge and
what I find is that this involves many
interesting aspects things like out of
distributions realization and system
original ization representation of
knowledge in a modular way that allows
sly compositional and like patient X
2-methyl learning because we can learn
the stable part of the knowledge as well
as how to on-the-fly combine those
pieces together this relates to
cognition and neuroscience especially of
attention and reasoning and
consciousness and it relates to agency
and non-stationarity
the Criers to be listed and I'm sure
we'll find more but uh maybe the central
prior is this idea well through central
priors that I've tried to highlight is
one that knowledge can be decomposed
into we combine Apple pieces
corresponding to dependencies involving
very few variables at a time and that
the way that knowledge changes over time
is local involving interventions that
involve only one or a few variables at a
time
so us is interesting because it allows
an agent to learn faster how to adapt to
a change in distribution or maybe even
just an inference in order to discover
the reasons why the change happened
connects to the actual language it
connects to the problem of discovering
causal dependencies connects to the
question of how meaning in natural
language be associated with both the
system one knowledge that we'll relates
perception to those high-level variables
and how these high-level variables
interact with each other in this very
structured way I think you said there is
that knowledge can be factorized it can
be decomposed into these relations which
can be recombined as you generalize and
in lots of out of domain situations that
seems completely reasonable to me that I
would still argue that the apparatus to
create those semantic relationships in
the first place is still is still
ineffective in the same way as it is now
with deep learning do you think of
features as a good semantic variable
features often are semantics I suppose
interim features are not necessarily
semantic but they they lead to a feature
of sufficient abstraction and relation
to things that we care about at some
point they become semantic you're like
if we think of lottery maybe these big
networks they even find all the features
that might exist and then markets are
like well here's the connection like
good job you found all these features
here the features you actually need
we're thinking of it as just connecting
features sequentially yeah then the
question is which which ones I mean
basically the model of the world he's
putting up here is that you have a world
model in your head that's the sparse
factor graph
and you basically only ever update a
small part of that factor graph and
because you have this assumption that of
localized change and so on and that's
what you said before where that ties in
right maybe you have the dense
computation but only on a sparse part on
a small part of that factor graph at a
time so you kind of focus your attention
on that's like if you if you learn
something new about physics
you're not gonna update your entire
you're not gonna question your knowledge
that you have about your tax form right
it's because you've learned something
about quantum physics like oh that's
interesting
you're not gonna revise everything it
may be that connects to how I wash my
back in the morning or you know that you
did this is this notion of localized
change and the boss localized changing
this factor graph and the way you learn
is you update a very small part still
leaves out the question of how do you
connect new things that's but maybe
we're terrible at that as humans maybe
that's a but I think the model is
incomplete I just want to point out that
this this graph isn't isn't really
source top-left everything's connected
to everything I think his system too
doesn't include I'm drawing pretty
slight deck so either strange every
every single thing is just like three
pixels over the the boxes aren't the
same size it's like this what happens
when you export like powerpoints and
then if you upload it to Google slides
and they download it again then you
convert it to a PDF so I think he's
built this in Microsoft Paint it can be
like a package like these lot tech
packages that build graphs for you right
really can control how they how they you
just say this should be connected and
they somehow figure out how that yeah
but ultimately I mean I get I get what
he's saying and it's that it's pretty
smart right and it's a good model I
disagree with some parts of that model I
question also the the
ability for us to learn this with the
techniques we have right now and I I'm
not sure and mostly I'm not sure how
that connects to consciousness I would
agree with that I think just to sum up
I've found it a bit difficult to wrestle
with this I think he's got some very
interesting ideas clearly he started off
the presentation by saying we've we've
gone a long way with consciousness
especially in the neuroscience world
consciousness is no longer a dirty word
and we should take all of the
information that we've learned from the
neuroscience world and we should
formalize it and we should build it into
our machine learning models yeah I'm
surprised that Agency is just black and
not red if that has any meaning one of
my favorite papers in his is experience
grounds language and I really like that
idea
how the agency like back to the idea
that like this like I believe my
knowledge because there is a reason to
do so
like I think agency also I would have
liked to have seen more what I really
loved was the beginning of this
presentation where he was using the
Daniel Kahneman formalism and talking
about the dichotomy between system 1 and
2 and how system 1 knowledge can't be
verbalized and a lot of that stuff has
given me a very useful framework to
think about AI systems in general and
interpret ability and how we should talk
about the capabilities within this
framework I think that was very useful
yeah I agree I'm not but I'm also
convinced that a system like that with
these kind of systems that we can just
approximate system to a system one liked
the idea of how this the skateboarder
who skateboards all day he can just
system one it whereas I would need to
plan it out so I think that with a
sufficiently powerful model and data you
could just I think that any assists most
not any but like most of the system to
stuff we think about could be
approximated in a intuitive kind of way
just a forward pass way that's
interesting with Yonex example with
alphago with the Monte Carlo tree search
I think that's just the perfect example
of system to system one so the Monte
Carlo tree search is like a planning way
to get a better act
but the way they do alphago zero is they
distill the Monte Carlo tree search as
actions into the first neural network so
this is the Intuit
intuitive system one thing and then this
distribution would be like I mean it
still back into the same thing but this
would be the system to result and I
think they do you know put the money
Carl at research into the policy pretty
well oh yes I I agree yeah that's that's
I mean the interface of system to the
system one I believe is more like a
guided search then it is maybe this this
factor graph thing but maybe there's a
way to combine the two like this search
will be over a factor graph cool why I
was gonna talk I think that like okay so
first there's this idea of measuring
types of generalization then I like the
neural module network so I want to talk
about that the idea of like I really
like this thing about how like if you're
gonna text my hand gesture it's better
to just first crop out my hand and then
do that so that it's like composing
these things you can do I like that a
lot
then the sparse representations you
didn't really talk about like meta
learning where you like take one task
and see what features or the variables
that connect the tasks even though I
think that's like something that huge
studies a lot and then I like the
awesome and then I like agency in
grounding although I didn't talk about
the hey I hope that you enjoyed NGOs
talk as much as we did and thank you so
much for being with us and we will see
you next week